all right he's the star of CW's cut and
seller fool us and author of the
bestseller presto how I made over a
hundred pounds disappear in other
magical tales Penn Jillette Harry Nelson
running Wow
you have lost a lot of way if you want
to statue win the goddamn war yeah there
you go
therefore rather glad they didn't I
don't know a black person also when he
says what does this lead to George
Washington statue being brought down
sure take them all down I don't know why
there should be statues of men on sub
public property
I mean Jefferson was against that we're
not supposed to be kings and people we
look up to let's all be able tear them
all down just hair down there paint
under statues no I would not even Gandhi
if we had a statue hammer I'm okay with
Gandhi and John Coltrane
in charge end of the list he's a North
Carolina well that's you know what
you're a shy man tonight I've always
been fascinated by your politics you
know I commend you because I know you
didn't like Hillary Clinton you're a
libertarian but you voted more that's
what a mature person does that make sure
person I learned the lesson that they
taught me at the SATs choose the best
answer there is not a perfect end I have
said a million times if you keep voting
for the lesser of two evils things just
keep getting more evil and I believe
that very very strongly but when it
finally came down to the actual moment I
know Donald Trump and whatever you think
about Donald Trump now worse don't wait
you're here
you're you're actually wrong when you
vote for the lesser of two evils things
get less II well yeah but in the long
run make it more iam but we know the
okay granite when I wrote that part out
the thing that really struck me is
listening to Al Franken listen everybody
out here a year ago I would have had a
zillion things to disagree without
Franken about now that we're here in
Trump
I don't think Al and I could talk for
three hours before we get to one point
we disagreed on is that exchanged
everything I want out of libertarian and
I am but still there's so much there's a
triage thing happening help is so
terrible he is you know I was always out
when you know Glenn Beck's the buddy of
mine and we always argue I disagree with
Glenn Beck on everything after Trump was
elected I I saw Glenn I sat down other
words ed do we disagree with anything
now he said no no disagree on it is off
is terrible it's the end of the world
we're done but you know as someone who
has been I've i guess in 1994 or
something I said something about
libertarianism and ever since they've
been bill you're not a real libertarian
I'm like you're right I'm not a real
liberal if I believe in smoking pot and
that's about it
but you are a real libertarian I believe
in not smoking pop I believe you should
be it well thanks so much now that it's
now that it's legal yeah he was out for
it before anymore oh it's cool
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm a married soon I'm the only person
who has never ever had a puff of
marijuana who's been on a cover of high
times and this several true because I
was so favored over the whole tattoo
figures they're very high of it I didn't
know the difference but what but
libertarianism okay my problem with it
is it goes too far I know you hosted the
debated I did the 2016 libertarian
convention look I was against suing the
tobacco company so I go with you that
far like people have to be responsible
but when it comes to land in the water
pesticides in the food
I mean look look at all the weight you
lost huh you probably ate good food I
did okay well without government help
you're not going to be able to even know
what good would it missus libertarian
libertarian is not is not an anarchist
now against all government is then I
think that it has to be done in a
case-by-case basis so I have one basic
question I asked which is any problem
that you have I like to ask the question
is there any way we can solve this with
less with more freedom instead of less
and sometimes the answer is no okay the
answer is no and I also think when as
soon as you say you're a libertarian the
first thing they say is you want to get
rid of all public schools and you want
that no food being regulated whatsoever
no water being regulated no the first
thing you want to get rid of is crony
capitalism the first you want to get rid
of is those kinds of payoffs the first
you want to get rid of is too bloated
government where people like Trump are
finding ways to gain the system and once
we get all of that out of the way then
we can discuss is there a better way to
maybe meet the government a little
leaner that's it's not estimating that
all sounds like common sense oh yeah
yeah but we didn't get you know there's
a lot I'm now going to say something
that you may actually hit me for there's
a lot of good he's not a violent guy
there's a lot of good there's going to
come out of Trump being president
one thing is we will rein in the power
of the president we have an absolute
full-blown dangerous whack job and now
we're learning how to get give less
power the other thing is we have
I'll prove and beyond a shadow of a
doubt that there's no Illuminati
there's no elders of zion there's no
area 50 War II through because if any of
you were in charge they would share
right right right the trilateral
connection yeah I was sure that so
president yes somebody would say listen
yes president
right we're really going to do when
you're an embolism in your sleep right
now now but now it turns out if you said
to be President
there's nobody stopping you and that's a
good thing to find out and that is a
great thing to find